we're asked to graph the solution set
for this system so we have two
inequalities here so this is a system of
inequalities and we know how to graph
them independently and so when you graph
the system you want to find the the set
of coordinates in the coordinate plane
that satisfy both of these inequalities
so essentially what we want to find out
where these two inequalities overlap so
let's graph this first one over here
I'll rewrite it in magenta Y is greater
than X minus 8 so the way to think about
this let's think about Y is equal to X
minus 8 but we're going to be greater
than that so we're going to draw a
dotted line at y is equal to X minus 8
so if you think about X minus 8 the
y-intercept is negative 8 so it's 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 that is negative 8 right there
this of course is the y-axis that is the
x-axis and the graph of y equals x minus
8 has a slope of 1 right there's one
times this X right here so every time
you move in the positive x-direction you
move one in the positive y-direction if
you move 2 you get 2 in the positive
y-direction if you move 2 3 you would go
up 3 in the positive y-direction and
likewise if you went negative
x-direction you'd also go in the
negative y-direction by 1 so this this
line if you said Y is equal to X minus 8
it would be a line just like that but
since we're not going to include it in
this set we have to be greater than that
line I'll do a dotted line here do my
best to draw a dotted line which is
surprisingly easier to draw than a non
dotted line so that is that is such a
dotted line version of y is equal to X
minus a but we're going to be greater
than that so for any X X minus 8 is
going to be on that line but the Y is
going to be all the values greater than
that so you pick any X this is X minus 8
the Y values going to be all the Y's
greater than that for that X so the
solution set for Y is greater than X
minus 8 is all of the area above this
line and it doesn't include it and
that's why I put a dotted line there so
let me do that in a lighter color so
it's literally all of this area up here
is the solution set for this first
inequality for this first inequality now
let's do the second
equality I'll do it another dark color
we have why is less than five minus X or
we could write that as negative x plus
five so it looks a little bit more like
our slope-intercept form now if we were
to just graph y is equal to negative x
plus five it would look like this we'd
go in the positive x positive
y-direction one two three four five that
is the y-intercept right there and it
has a slope of negative one so if we
move one in the x direction we move down
one if we move three in the x direction
we're going to move down three if we
move back three in the extracts we're
going to move up three so this line is
going to look like this
and I'm going to do it a dotted line
because we're not including it it's not
less than or equal it's just strictly
less than so it won't include the line
so it's going to look something like
this try my best to draw it as neatly as
possible I think that is a respectable
job this is the dotted line version of y
is equal to negative x plus five it's
dotted because we're not including it
now for any X you pick an X let's say
the X is equal to one negative x plus
five is going to get onto that line but
for that X we only care about the Y's
that are less than that value so it's
going to be all the values below this
line so if you look at the solution set
for this second inequality it will look
like this it will look like and I'll do
it in this light blue color it will look
something like this it'll be all of the
area below this blue line so it will be
all of this area below the blue line now
what we care about is the the set of
coordinates that satisfy both of these
inequalities now in order to satisfy
both the inequalities it has to be the
overlap of the solution sets and the
overlap of the solution sets where the
blue is overlapping with the yellow in
this case is everything that is above
this line and everything that's below
that line so it's all of this area here
and so let me color that in a little bit
bolder so it's all of this below the
blue line above the red line this is the
overlap all of this area all of that
area right there is the solution set for
this system and you can verify it pick a
random point in this air
and see it'll satisfy both points and a
really easy one is X is equal to zero Y
is equal to zero that's part of our
solution set let's try it out if Y is
zero zero is greater than zero minus
eight that's true zero is greater than
negative eight if you do the second
equation zero is less than five minus
zero that's true zero is less than five
and you can try it out with any points
here this orange area is our solution
set